freunde herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video endlich mal wieder soweit
ich habe mir etwas besonderes für euch
überlegt ihr habt schon im titel gelesen
ich werde 24 stunden mit diesem iphone 4
dem iphone 3gs über die man kann es
wahrscheinlich überleben nennt das ist
jetzt genau zehn jahre alt und das hier
ist mein aktuelles iphone das iphone app
von afflecks ich habe aber dumm ein
anderes volk kaputt gemacht und man
sieht schon da ist ein kleiner
unterschied da also die handys sind
wahrscheinlich auch technisch nicht ganz
auf einem stand wir haben hier drei
riesige mega kameras wirst es eine
webcam kamera so gefühlt mittlerweile
das ist wirklich nichts besonderes mehr
aber ich werde testen was kann man mit
diesem handy überhaupt noch machen und
kann man damit in der heutigen zeit noch
überleben so whatsapp instagram keine
ahnung ich teste alles aus aber weil ich
nicht genau weiß ob ich damit wirklich
auf what's up benutzen kann wenn ich
jetzt erstmal aufwärts gehen die app
über die ich am meisten kommuniziere und
mein status ändern in 24 stunden nur
über telefon erreichbar
dann würde ich sagen mach ich das handy
jetzt die autos bleibt jetzt aus für 24
stunden
ok jetzt an der stelle vielen lieben
dank verbrauchenden wir das handy
geliehen hat dass ich das video
überhaupt drehen konnte weil es nicht
meint so leute gesperrte sim-karte das
heißt ich kann jetzt meine pin eingeben
und dann hoffe ich dass es funktioniert
weil sonst habe ich eine pin-eingabe
erfolgreich ihre suchen neues probieren
aber ich habe eh alter [ __ ] und ein
balken ich habe normalerweise tollen
empfang und älter also lte gab es ja
damals gar nicht mehr ich habe jetzt
selbst noch mal eingegeben und ich teste
jetzt mal ihn anzurufen
james handy klingelt es funktioniert
perfekt ist die hilfe am boden jetzt
nicht so überraschend gewesen aber ich
bin mir sicher dass mit relativ viele
changes mit sich bringt mit diesem handy
zu überleben wir gehen jetzt erstmals
fitnessstudio deshalb jetzt mir übrigens
auch die ganze zeit schon im auto fertig
gefragt habt und lasst uns diesen tag
beginnt menü und probiere meine airports
zu verbinden will weil ich mein herz
ausgang gab es das handy
also war davon jahre alt probier's mal
direkt angezeigt was das leben verbunden
ich habe überhaupt keine und oh mein
gott das musica natürlich lieber mal auf
soundcloud jetzt mit 3g und mein gott
umfeld
kurz gesagt die seite lädt einfach nicht
lässt sich nun als letztes für die dies
mega gespannt und mitwirken oder
vielleicht auch einfach nicht nur noch
länger 3g war so langsam kam damals
wahrscheinlich nicht so vor aber das
geht jetzt nicht älter mir fällt gerade
auf ich habe gerade den du hast dich
gehört und tastatur das heißt ich habe
entscheiden über die airports in meinem
ort stellt das funktioniert
50.000 aufbruch christina graf mich
allerdings funktioniert oh mein gott das
format spricht weil es mir zu und die
qualität auch fall klar
[Musik]
ja
wirklich hat die ganze zeit in days
handy gefilmt das ist das iphone 3g s
[Musik]
was machen wir mit dem modell
ich bin mit so bastian
hier bin ich mit meinem handy ich hab
bisher eigentlich irgendwelche probleme
bestanden weil ich mein handy kaum
benutzt habe ich mal trainieren konnte
die musik hören haben ein zwei
telefonate geführt das funktioniert auch
ganz ohne probleme
aber ich war den ganzen tag noch nicht
auf weil ich glaube ich nicht auch
whatsapp kann ich muss gleich mal testen
ob ich mir die app installieren kann
aber so essen gehen so fotos machen
eigentlich alles ganz normal
nur dass die qualität von den fotos ein
bisschen schlecht ich meine ich dass ich
ein bisschen was eingesendet bisher aber
eigentlich echt nicht voll einfache
erfahrungen ich weiß auch nicht was ich
erwartet habe ich meine das ist ja nicht
so als sei das so steinzeit
technologisch aber irgendwie muss ich
sagen ist das alles ganz schön
entspannen kann ja nicht aufschreiben
wollte mich nur mal melden
zumal gott leute ich habe eine sms
geschickt in der sms geschichte fühlt
wie im mittelalter
es gibt von moobicent e mobil wie kann
man kommunizieren
wigan seinem team zum ausbringen oder
emerging wie vor eine kleine sagte von
mir durch die iphone 3gs kamera ich kann
mir kein roboter installiert
das liegt daran nicht das projekt
funktioniert oder nicht aber ich kann
die örtlichen verliert weil das
interface
das tätigen moskau zum anlesen die einen
gehen muss
ich bin noch ein leichtes gewesen das
einzige was mir auffällt ist ich
verschwende viel weniger zeit am handy
einfach weil ich kein hilfsprogramm und
sowas benutzen kann wollte ich kann das
ganze familie das gilt also das ist
wirklich lachen prozent jetzt schnell
also vergleichsweise schnell eigene
überraschend schnell dafür dass es so
heiß ist aber die ganzen apps
funktionieren
und dadurch verschwinden viel weniger
zeit an wenn die freunde der glatten
video für dave gedreht und dabei es
sieht mittlerweile wieder alles relativ
gut aus ist meine gesamte küche geworden
das heißt ihr müsst weil dave auf dem
channel vorbei schaut euch das video
anschauen
die ganzen details erkennen man jetzt
gar nicht dafür wollen fällt sondern
eine spülmaschine aus aber wir sind
heute so productive dass ich gar nicht
merke dass ich nur telefonieren und sms
schreiben ist das eigentlich fertig neid
aber mir ist das auge fallen natürlich
zeigen wollte und es funktioniert
einfach airplay und diesen werden die
zehn jahre steht darauf gekommen
so leute jetzt guck ich das an ich kann
einfach hier auf airplay klicken
wohnzimmer auswählen das ist der apple
tv und jetzt passiert was da vorne
gucken konnte nicht abgeschlossen so
geil leute testen
[Musik]
okay leute ich nehme alles zurück
er wird zwar angezeigt aber es
funktioniert mich sehr aber auch zu
krass gewesen wenn es funktionieren
würde ich jetzt auch irgendwie aber ich
bin auf jeden fall nicht zum laufen
leute haben jetzt die ganze zeit gedreht
für date und mich und selbst mich aber
ich werde es nicht auch wir sitzen
lassen dass ich keine apps installieren
kann irgendwie langsam hätte ich schon
mal gerne irgendwie instagram und könnte
schauen was abgeht ist aber ansonsten
ich gar kein problem wenn man etwas zu
tun hat so wie immer meine kenntnis ist
wenn man immer gerne sachen die man
verwenden zu sein
ich habe endlich hinbekommen ich würde
meine apple id anzumelden und dann das
hier
diese applikation erfordert als 8 oder
neuer perfekt geht also nicht wir haben
ios 6 auf diesem handy installiert zu
vergleichen sind aktuell bei ios 13
sondern wir das ganz bei instagram
aussieht das war's auch schon langsam
youtube
doodle jump kommt vom klassiker das ist
so langsam dass es unglaublich ok komm
schon und o mein gott du kannst die
letzte kompatible version da die ja
leute seht ihr das wenn alles glatt
läuft dann installiere ich jetzt gerade
doodle jump auf dem iphone 3gs das hat
wirklich funktioniert seht ich hier vorn
hier isst du dich habe ich klicke mal
drauf die app startet ich konnte mir
eine app runterladen copyright 2015 war
damals iphone 3g und leute richtig
flashback also das hätte ich immer so
schlimm aus durch kamera durch ich hatte
damals so einen krassen heizkörper to
gesamten aber voll geil dass wir das man
bei doodle jump alte version
installieren kann also instagram und
whatsapp ihr habt ja gesehen gehen beide
gar nicht aber durch sie damals so vor
acht jahren oder so habe ich damals
immer mein ipod und meine iphones mit
jailbreak und sowas erinnert mich gerade
richtig an die zeit irgendwie so das so
kompliziert runterzuladen und dann so zu
spielen wie wenn man in der schule die
lampe spiel ist natürlich zu empfehlen
aber ihr mit einer hand finde ich habe
ich fünf mal wie weit ich schaffe und
dann melde ich mich wieder voll okay
leute das war meine allererste runde
96.000 ich bin ein bisschen braut muss
ich sagen
wisst ihr noch eure nudeln reis wenn ihr
dann schreibt man unten die kommentare
was aber heißt bewahren oder vielleicht
spielt das ja auch jetzt noch auf jeden
fall ganz nette abwechslung mal das
zocken zu können auf dem handy
ich probiere schon ein bisschen aus was
ich mir so an apps installieren kann
aber vielleicht youtube sonst finde ich
auch fast nichts mehr ein was es so
richtig regelmäßig benutzt wenn wir für
sie trotzdem einen youtube punkt einfach
mal wir sehen uns dann gleich
ich werde es auf dem weg ins kino und
ich hab mir gedacht ich dokumentiere den
rest des abends einfach mit dem iphone 3
also lässt
[Musik]
und dann fing ich film dann auch ja
okay leute das waren 24 stunden mit dem
iphone 3gs ich habe ja nichts mehr
gemacht nachdem ich im kino war
ich muss wirklich sagen überraschend wie
gut das ganze noch funktioniert
irgendwie das seien mehr challenge klar
also es nicht installieren könnte ist
komplett beschissen und würde das handy
für mich zumindest komplett unbrauchbar
machen aber man konnte eigentlich
relativ gut überlegen in 1 42 stimmen
sind jetzt auch eine ewigkeit ist jetzt
ja auf jeden fall zusammen mit dave und
startete sofort das video für euch
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen was gut
bist du nicht mal und tschüss